I'm honored to be here today we present
a talk about machine learning's
integrability and this is our agenda for
today we will in the beginning motivate
the talk why you would need machine
learning framework into operability and
we do that by introducing an end-to-end
Pipeline and having this pipeline then
we can discuss common bottlenecks such
as memory management data conversion
data loading data transfers in the end
we wrap up the talk and we give a
summary some take home message as well
as information for you so you can try
this at home so let's let's motivate the
top and on this slide you see three
different professionals the very left
the data scientist wearing white scrubs
I know that's not usually what we wear a
Cuda developer with a black shirt that
other people usually implementing low
level Cuda kernels whenever speed is a
matter and then we often have also data
Engineers which try to identify new
sources of data as well as cleaning the
data and they all might have different
preferences preferences for machine
learning Frameworks that could be for
example one of the most popular deep
learning Frameworks pytorch or
tensorflow or we could work with tabular
data then Rapids might come into play
numeric data then we might want to have
a look at qpi that's the green logo in
the upper right but sometimes you would
also want to implement a Cuda kernel
from within python that would be number
the the framework in the lower left
legit compilation is also interesting
both in numerics as well as deep
learning and there is a framework
proposed by Google called Jax and this
is in particular nice when you need
forward mode Auto diff or backward mode
Auto div and and all these have
advantages and disadvantages and so the
different people might choose different
Frameworks and our job is to explain how
they could interoperate and let's see on
the next slide what is the content of
this talk we will start introducing such
an end-to-end pipeline for
basically outlier detection of
heartbeats then we will discuss how data
has to be copied in between those
Frameworks and on the right you see a
nice overview how this can be done and
we talk about that in detail we will
dive down on um
memory layouts memory management memory
pools uh data conversion and in the very
end we will discuss Hardware accelerated
copying using RDMA to basically avoid
the CPU while copying data back and
forth and okay let's start
let's have a look at the pipeline we
coded that pipeline in a jupyter
notebook for you so you can try it at
home on the left you will see the full
pipeline for the hard segmentation and I
will explain it in detail in a sec we
also provide a jupyter notebook with a
conversion table that shows the code
Snippets how to convert data from one
framework to another efficiently
and let's dive into the end-to-end
pipeline
yeah this will be a toy model so not not
a real application and practice we are
basically going to uh segment 20 hours
of ECG streams of heartbeats basically
continuously measured and they are
stored in CSV format on disk right our
job will be to segment them into
isolated heartbeats that will be 100
000k and then Train A variation in Auto
encoder for outlayer detection also for
generating new heartbeats whenever you
have to convince someone that you're
still alive you could generate some
heartbeats of course you want to
visualize them and that will also be
part of it on the left side you see
um the enumeration of different segments
in a heartbeat usually with letters pqrs
and T I will sometimes refer to them but
don't overthink it and the disclaimer
this is a toy model don't diagnose heart
diseases with that at home leave that to
The Experts so let's dive into there
the um first part uh let's let's keep it
real most of the time someone will just
enter the room and give you a hard drive
with data on it or or point you to some
cloud storage with a CSV file we could
argue that there are better formats to
store time series but it's not unusual
to get it in CSV and we would have to
pause it you could use pandas for uh for
pausing it but here we use Rapids qdf
which is a GPU enabled dropping
replacement for pandas and many people
don't know that's actually quite
expensive to pass floating Point data
stored in ASCII on disk and therefore
it's a good idea to actually do that on
a GPU and you will end up with a data
frame that lives already on the GPU you
can see that on the right on that slide
okay we have the data on the GPU and be
composite at the speed of light that's
great but now we would like to isolate
them remember continuously measured
heartbeats so we need some mechanism to
to isolate them so we have different
heartbeats we can achieve that with a
convolution here we choose a global
convolution with a wavelet being
accelerated by a Fourier transform you
could implement it in numpy very easily
but again since uh we want to be on the
GPU for the sake of the huge compute
capability and memory bandwidth we
choose Q Pi which is a drop in
replacement and to achieve that we would
have to copy the data from Rapids to qpi
and and therefore here the first problem
arises we need to transfer data going on
we would on the next slide we can see
that that we would then want to embed
the heartbeats of potentially different
length into a data Matrix of fixed shape
and there is no good convenient tool to
do that either in Rapid or coupon but
it's very easy to do that writing a
custom kernel a Cuda kernel and number
which is basically writing Cuda Clinic
from within Python and we we will
achieve that and it's actually not hard
you can see it in the notebook
nevertheless we have to copy the data
again on the right you see the embedding
we basically embed each heartbeat in a
fixed length Vector of 250 we will also
normalize it by removing the mean and
equalizing the amplitude well and now we
have a huge data Matrix of a hundred
thousand heart beats and we would
Like To Train A variation out encoder in
pytorch and this is what we do here this
is a vanilla variation autoencoder as
proposed by King minus PhD thesis
basically a normal Auto encoder with uh
the exception that in the latent space
in the middle you basically uh enforce
that the points are distributed
according to a prior probability
distribution in this case it's a
gaussian so we're decompressing a
heartbeat of length 250 uh to two points
in to a two D point in the plane and you
basically see a scatter plot which are
ordered um
heartbeats whenever they are in the
middle of the gaussian that means they
are quite usual or quite common under
the training set and if you find a cross
in the outer region that means that is
an unusual heartbeat uh probably an
outlier and then you can decode it with
the right side of the topology again to
be a heartbeat and this is how it Trends
it basically train it for the identity
again we need to copy that data and we
can finally visualize it using Rapids Q
cross filter and here we could either
take the the 2D points in in the plane
and uh pass it through that decoder
um
or we could even come up with new points
that we synthetically put into the plane
and Sample it that's what we did on the
right nine different heartbeats uh the
the coordinates are the coordinates in
latent space whenever the numbers are
big so not near the origin that means
this is an unusual heartbeat for example
the last row in the middle column this
is quite unusual
good uh the the conclusion is we have to
copy data quite a lot and this could
take a a lot a huge amount of time to be
honest and on the next slide we see
basically different Frameworks that
could be used to achieve the chain the
same you could decide just these
tensorflow instead of Pi torture you
could decide to uh perform
um the Fourier transform in numpy
instead of Q Pi or use panels for
parsing it of course as an Nvidia
employee I will tell you the more green
you see the better the pipeline will be
in terms of throughput and latency and
on the next slide we will discuss in
detail how you can identify the pipeline
foreign
are the boxes either in green or blue
whenever it's green it's an in a GPU
accelerator framework such as tensorflow
or if it's blue it's a CPU based
framework such as pandas and the edges
in between those nodes those are the
conversion paths how you could pass data
from one framework to another whenever
it's green this is a zero copy Edge and
that means that we can pass data even
without copying we're basically just
forwarding a pointer with some
information attached to it and this is
really fast the fastest way to copy data
is not to copy it at all whenever it's
black it means we actually have to copy
data but and whenever we have to copy
data between a blue and a green
framework that means that this has to
Traverse PCI Express which is slow
compared to for example just copying
data and GPU memory good
and not there's not always an edge
between all pairs sometimes you have to
Stage memory for example when copying
data from pandas to number you would
have to introduce an intermediate hop
which would be qdf and therefore this is
quite useful uh illustration so let's
have a look at the next slide
ah it's actually the introduction for
migrants part who will now talk about
memory layouts memory management
thank you Christian and thank you
everyone for joining us today so
I like to create this kind of a slides
that doesn't say anything but they say a
lot so you all know the Cookie Monster
so give me more cookies and that
represents what happens with the
libraries we use today with tensorflow
Pythons or whatever they are really
greedy they want to get as much memory
as possible
um by themselves why because memory
allocations are the allocations is
really expensive so what they think is
okay I will pre-allocate 90 of them GPU
memory available and I will just manage
it internally but I will pre-allocate it
once only what happens that if you have
a complex pipeline as ours or SARS any
other people pipelines you have two
Frameworks fighting for the available
memory so so that's that's not good that
we need to find a solution for that I
agree to to share the the memory between
different Frameworks and that is what it
is a memory manager so Under the
Umbrella of Rapids and for those who
doesn't know it a rapid is a developing
replacement for other libraries such as
pandas second layer Network X and many
others with dropping replacement I mean
uh same API but running everything on
gpus multiple gpus or multiple nodes so
as an example instead of import pandas
SPD you do import qdf SPD and you can do
the same as you do with with pandas but
on a GPU environment much faster
actually so under that umbrella we
created Rapids memory manager which is
just an external locator which is a
piece of software that you can plug into
your software to deal with the memory
allocations and the allocations
alongside with other things like for
instance it lets you do login double
check links limiting the amount of
memory per consumer and the great news
is that this is open source all the code
you think you have and it is already
integrated by multiple libraries like XC
books python number could buy all Rapids
Frameworks so that means that they will
all share the same memory so they don't
need to fight for the memory they will
just query us to rapidly manager the the
memory they need and it will be provided
to them and we will have that
orchestrator which is a rmm so a really
nice nice tool and we keep on adding
other libraries integrated on this on
this Library
um why are we talking about copying data
data conversion bottlenecks so the
reality is that when we started dealing
with these Frameworks nobody thought
about multiple pipelines
interoperability so what happens for
instance imagine that you have your data
in parquet format and you want to load
it with spark 2.x for instance the
previous version or with pandas so
pandas usually deals with the data in
our row wise layout that we will see
what's that later but part K organized
the data in columns in in the disk so
when you are loading the data you are
not only loading the data but also
transposing it converting that to a
target a data layout in memory and that
is very consuming how much so around 70
of your computational time is wasted on
those kinds of serialization deservation
transposing changing data types that is
really really unconvenient for our
purpose what happens if we all adopt and
understand that in this case this is
Apache Ro in memory data layout
specification so we just need to pass a
pointer to the to the data to the other
library and they will know how to deal
with that and that is the the current
approach most of the libraries currently
Implement Apache Ro columnar layout and
and they make use of it and that makes
our our interaction our interoperability
much much better
just very briefly
um why columnar data layout so basically
because most of the operation not all of
them but most of the operations that we
perform with data science benefit of
organizing the data in columns instead
of rows let me give you one example for
instance we would like to calculate the
mean of all the timestamps this is a row
wise layout Okay so
if we want to calculate the mean we need
to read all the values and then sum them
up and divide by the total number of
values so we have multiple memory
readings on different memory locations
what happens if you have all the data
located in a columnar layout at once you
can read everything at once calculate
the the sum and divide and this is this
is much much more efficient likewise if
we are filtering by Source IP or sorting
by user ID
and the second thing is that Colorado's
deals really well with with gpus they
are like a perfect match being fair CPUs
introduced a single instruction multiple
data instruction set to also deal with
coronal data so it is a win-win
regardless if you use CPU so if you
organizing your data in columns it's
usually very good for your Pipelines
um so we I mentioned apacheara and this
is one specification we'll use but there
are other alternative specifications
which are very compatible between them
like DL pack dlpac lets you exchange 10
Source between libraries so for instance
you have a panda set offering or a PDF
data frame in in GPU memory and I want
to to compare that to a coupon
array so I just need to do
and they are basically exchanging
pointers the data itself is not
converted it's not move and that is
really really efficient now for instance
if you have a an array in coupon here
and we want to create a touch tensor we
just need to do to deal back in the
source part and from their pack in the
destination path really really efficient
zero copy everything remains in GPU
memory if you are dealing with two GPU
based library and if you are dealing
with CPU based Library they will remain
both in host memory but there are other
approaches for instance we have kudara
interface that it was one specification
we invented available which is also used
and it's really really interesting and
likewise it maintains the the memory uh
organizing a very similar way to deal
back um
so when you are exchange using a
framework that organizes the data into
the right interface and you want to pass
it to a framework that only accepts deal
pack do not worry about that because it
will be zero copy too it's only just a
couple of headers that will be
transformed
how does it work
um I'm finishing almost there is that
for instance imagine we have some python
code this is number okay number lets you
decorate some python code and it will
tell convert this python code into
cudakota will run on Nvidia gpus in
adjusting time Manner and then we have
another function here this function is
dealing with a coupon array in the
arrays and we are using it as a input
values for the next functionality so we
just take this input value and pass it
as a parameter to the the safe mode
kernel that is expected a device in the
array but what happens is that because
coupon a number both Implement under the
hood could array interface I can just
pass this this object safely to safely
to to the library and it is understood
so zero copy again very interesting
thing we have 40 standards let's create
a 15 standard so that is data API but
the reality is that it is doing really
well it is a a Consortium of members of
the industry we have people from goodbye
from tensorflow from Peter from Nvidia
for many different players trying to
create a standard and a standard in both
the functionality the the nomenclature
of the method itself to name the same
functionality in the same way and also
how to organize the data and all the
things it is a really nice approach it
is working we have already the first
version of of the specification and this
is the the standard until we find
another standard basically
um I think that with that I will pass
the ball again to Christian to talk
about that alone in bottlenecks
Christian please happy to continue yeah
let's let's discuss a little bit about
Hardware
in the next slide you will see uh the
PCI Express topology of a GPU being
connected to PC Express switch and we
also see an nvme drive and also the CPU
being connected to it so if we would
copy data from the nvme drive to the GPU
usually we would have to involve the CPU
basically what happens is that we stage
the data in the ram of the CPU and then
copy it back to the GPU interestingly
specifically when you talk about sales
with tons of gpus like 8 or 16 gpus you
have a significantly smaller amount of
CPUs therefore this might not scale
specifically when you have to copy tons
of data let's dive into that in detail
on the next slide for example
uh we see that we could uh by
introducing RDMA which uh with the
Nvidia flavor called GPU direct storage
we could communicate between the nvme
derive and the GPU without involving the
CPU and that is basically saving you uh
valuable flops on the CPU set which
makes your application scale and maybe
let's have a look uh here at
um a data loader the rapid
qioczv data loader implemented in
different ways and you see the uh the
slowest variant is the the dark green
one at the bottom which basically does
the naive approach as well as a scalar
approach it is the blue one where the
throughputs gets almost linearly with
the number of gpus and now just imagine
what happens if you're bound by the CPU
that is the green line when you increase
the number of gpus you're basically
dividing that throughput by the number
of gpus for each of the gpus and that's
not what you want you want this linear
scaling so such as in the blue line and
therefore it makes tons of sense to use
RDMA capability let's maybe have a look
at a few more
examples
here we Illustrated the naive way
copying data from one GPU to another
I already said it we would have to
involve the CPU copying it in Ram then
copying back of our PCI Express so we
finally end up in the GPU buff of the
second GPU and this is completely
Superfluous because they are both
attached to the same PCX press bus on
the next slide we see we could directly
copy it
um
from one GPU to the other which saves us
at least the staging and CPU memory
which which is awfully slow but here we
basically have a factor of two but it
can be much worse let's maybe have a
look at the next scenario when we have
several gpus in different servers being
interconnected by a network and in the
naive way we would have to copy data
from one GPU to another as follows
copying it involving the CPU to Ram then
staging it in the driver buffer of the
network device then copying it via the
network to the staging buffer of the
other network device then copying it
back
uh to the driver buffer of the other
server
exactly now this happens and then
copying it over PC Express to the other
GPU five copy operations incredibly
expensive when we have Nvidia networking
devices as well as Nvidia gpus all
connected to the same PC express bus as
well as using Infinity band we can
actually copy it from the left to the
right without involving a CPU at all
that's what it is one copy operation you
just divided the number of copy
operations by a factor five which can
make a huge impact in your pipeline
maybe on the next slide a high level
view of the same scenario you could even
use dpus instead of normal Infinity band
devices to communicate those are
basically network devices with an
attached CPU on it to accomplish
different tasks such as encryption and
in a multi-tenancy setting when you want
to making sure that nobody can listen to
the data being communicated between the
service it could encrypt it even fully
transparent to application and allowing
this RDMA functionality and that's a
good reason to purchase Nvidia gpus and
and Nvidia networking devices yeah
that's basically what I wanted to show
let me summarize what we have seen
different people have different needs
and different preferences and there's a
good reason that there are many
different Frameworks with strengths and
weaknesses and therefore complex
workloads might be composed of different
Frameworks and the job is to basically
reduce the impact of communication this
can be achieved by a zero copy mechanism
such as the other pack or the or the
Cuda array interface if you can avoid to
copy data at all do it that's a good
idea and memory management should not be
underestimated allocating data and
deallocating it it's actually expensive
RDMA features such as GPU direct storage
and GPU direct peer-to-peer are really
good to avoid meaningless copies that's
all what we wanted to show we packed all
the information into Jupiter notebooks
and if you are a person that likes to
read
over listening to us here there's a
series of post which explains everything
in detail give you more information
there's a slightly longer talk on it for
on the GPU technology conference as well
as the two Jupiter notebooks noted and
as a final command if you want to
interact with Nvidia they are plenty
ways how to achieve that
you're very much a developer focused
company therefore it's always good to to
register on the developer Pages it's
basically just leaving us an email if
you're a startup we have a dedicated
program for that called Nvidia Inception
if you want to learn more about gpus as
well as the Frameworks running on it
there's a deep learning Institute either
for remote hands-off courses or or you
could even book an experienced
instructor to come to your company and
of course we're interfacing also with
Academia and
r d on the next slide there's a little
bit more information about the sdks that
we have whenever you are in a domain
specific setting could be Quantum
computation so that you actually want to
simulate Quantum circuits could be a NLP
could be
um spasm metrics algebra we have sdks
for that optimized for you we uh have a
very strong research organization NV
research which is publishing papers we
also put all those info all those
findings into webinars and blogs such as
today and we have developer from forums
where you can reach out to us and
sometimes even if you have a very
complicated application it would be a
shame that's not running on GPS we have
hackathons and we're supporting events
such as this one that's all we wanted to
show today
thank you very much for having us and if
you have questions we are happy to take
them